jusqu'à présent l'yonne est découpé en
42 cantons en 2015 il n'y en aura plus
que la moitié les cantons très peu
peuplée seront rattachés à des villes
afin que chaque conseiller soit élu avec
un nombre de voix équivalant mais loin
d'y voir une mesure d'égalité les
conseillers généraux de droite dénoncent
une manipulation politique de la gauche
et un abandon des territoires ruraux
c'est une manoeuvre strictement
électoral politicienne qui n'a rien à
voir avec la réalité de nos territoires
ruraux sur le futur canton de chablis
par exemple qui fait 80 kg qui fera 80
km de long et qui comptera 65 communes
comment deux élus un homme et une femme
normalement constitué vont pouvoir être
en phase avec les préoccupations des
populations concernées par ces
territoires
les élus de gauche explique qu'il s'agit
d'un nécessaire rééquilibrage dans
l'yonne le plus petit canton compte à
l'heure actuelle deux mille électeurs
contre 19,8 pour le plus gros bon ce
n'est pas une manoeuvre politicienne vis
que sous le gouvernement précédent il
était prévu qu'il n'ya même plus de
conseillers généraux mais des
conseillers territoriaux
donc qui à ce moment là aurait englober
et les départements et les régions
donc il y aurait une proximité beaucoup
moins importante que celle qui va y
avoir là alors manoeuvres politiciennes
ou pas reste que tous les précédents
découpages accusé de favoriser un camp
n'ont jamais eu les résultats escomptés
la réforme parce qu en 86 n'avait pas
empêché la réélection de mitterrand
pas plus que le quinquennat n'avait
permis à jospin d'être élu président de
la république